So, hi everybody.
Uh, today I'm gonna tell you about Guardian Agent.
A tool we've built for Secure Delegation for the SSH protocol.
And towards the end of the talk,
I'm also gonna [NOISE] discuss how this
tool we've built as well as the principles behind it,
uh, allow us to address other authorization scenarios,
and and not only SSH.
[NOISE] But we're gonna start with SSH,
and we're gonna see how does- uh,
to see how delegation works today in SSH.
Let us consider the following scenario
that many of you are probably gonna be familiar with.
So, imagine a user connecting to some,
er, Cloud Machine of her choice,
and that user wants to clone her private Gi- to- Git repository located on GitHub.
And the repository being private of course,
[NOISE] uh, cloning this repository,
requires the user to authenticate.
[NOISE]. Uh, but the private key of the user is
located on her local machine on her laptop.
And obviously she would like to avoid just u- uploading, and,
an- uploading her key to those,
to this Cloud Machine which could be potentially untrusted.
While this seems kind of,
um, like a kind of basic scenario,
and i- it also seems like there're SSH protocol,
and the SSH tool chain are kind of a,
kind of thitherward, and we have a solution for that.
So, what can the user do?
[NOISE] Um, the user can run, [NOISE] uh,
can run an SSH agent locally,
and add her key to that SSH agent.
And to be extra secure, she's also gonna, uh,
add this minus c flag that is going to ask that
such that the agent is going to ask her every time her key is getting used.
So she'll know exactly, uh, how the key is used.
Then, [NOISE] uh, the user is gonna, uh, SSH,
and enable agent forwarding,
uh, when she connects to the Cloud Machine.
And then, when she runs that,
uh, when she runs the git clone command, uh,
the authentication request is going to get forwarded, uh,
to the local agent, who's going to prompt the user to confirm the use of her key.
And it looks like problem solved.
So the user knows every time her key is used,
she can confirm it, she can deny,
she has full control of her credentials.
But, if you look closely at this prompt to the user, er,
that the users get you kind of see that it doesn't
really provide us with the guarantee that we would want.
So what does the user see on this prompt basically,
she sees the path to a local key not really the kind of
information that you want to have once you're confirming the operation.
And so, when the user clicks "OK",
and she think- she thinks she authorizes that the Cloud Machine to clone her repository,
if that Cloud Machine is compromised or maybe the entire Cloud provider is compromised,
then, well she thinks she's signing, uh,
a challenge use for authentication to GitHub that malicious Cloud,
Cloud provider could actually use that sign authentication challenge in order to
perform some different malicious operation on
a completely different host to which the user has access.
And what is kind of the root cause for- for this problem?
Well, the root cause is that with the current way that this protocol, uh,
is used and all the tools around it are built that the user can clearly verify
the identity of the delicate- the delegate to whom she delegates her credentials.
So, when she see- sees this prompt she doesn't
really know that this challenge that originates from one,
from, from GitHub, or does it originate from some, some different host.
And also the user cannot really verify the command that, uh,
that, uh, this authorization is going to be- is going to be used for.
And the identity of the server and the delegate, both,
are kind of untied, uh,
when you- when she sees that, uh, authentication challenge.
And it's important to stress that this is not merely a UI issue.
So, it's not just we could change that prompt and display some other uh,
maybe more important information.
In fact this type of information isn't really available to the client.
And of course there are
no any cryptographic guarantees that when you when- you signed this challenge,
what does this challenge going to be used for?
So, the picture today is that by approving this,
uh, approving these kind of prompts,
we are essentially signing a blank check.
So, we put our signature there, uh,
and we don't even specify the amount of money,
what's the command that we're going to run.
We don't specify the, the recipient,
the identity of the server on which the command is going to run,
and maybe even the identity of like the bank if I have multiple bank accounts is
also not set to relate to the previous stock.
So, what do we really want?
So what we want is instead of- [NOISE], uh,
instead of having this kind of not very useful prompt that doesn't allow us to
control the delegation what we wanna have is- we wanna have uh,
uh, we wanna have an authorization decision that has all the scope,
all the necessary scope to make a meaningful decision.
So at a minimum,
we would like to know who are we delegating to?
What can the delegate do with our identity and to whom.
So for example, what's the in- what's the server to which the operation will be applied.
And again I want to stress out that,
it's not kind of a- it's not on the UI issue but kind of uh,
protocol [NOISE] there is a protocol issue here as well.
Um, so, and if you think that this is kind of an issue that's only,
only present on SSH and other protocols get it right.
Well, similar scenarios is not exactly of this type,
but similar scenarios involving, uh,
unscoped delegation exist in other protocols as well.
So for example, for PLS,
we can consider this scenario in which some publisher wants to
delegate the duty of serving its home page to a Cloud,
uh, to a Content Delivery Network, a CDN,
and of course the publisher wants to still serve his,
uh, serve his homepage, uh, using HTTPs.
So, to do that, uh,
currently, what is required is that for the publisher,
it needs to give the certificate as well as
the private key corresponding this certificate to the CDN,
uh, for the user to get an HTTPS connection.
But once the publisher
gives access to its private key to the content delivery network,
if the content delivery network is compromised, or is malicious,
then he can use, um,
he can use this credential to serve some other content.
So, in a- in- in essence,
the publisher delegates his identity without,
uh, without sufficient control.
And there have been like rec- there have been recent works, for example,
the work by CloudFlare called KeylessTLS, which is er,
which in essence is very similar to SSH agent and suffer from similar problems.
So, with KeylessTLS,
the solution works by the publisher keeping the private key.
So in this picture you can see that the private key is kept,
is kept by the publisher.
And then, every time the, the CDNs,
every time that the CDN wants to establish
a secure HTTPS connection as the server, he's gonna,
uh, uh, er, he's going to talk to the publisher,
and send him th- send him a challenge,
and gonna get a signature or decryption depending on the,
uh, uh, encryption protocol used.
We- so this- so if you look at this solution in essence,
the reason that I said it's kind of similar to SSH agent is that
the publisher really exposes a signing oracle here.
So, he tells the CDN just send me those challenges and I'm gonna sign them.
Do I know how they're,
gonna use it. Not really.
So if the CDN really wants to manipulate the content, uh, he can do that,
and for example, the identity of the client is also not verified,
um, in this case.
So, in our work, we started off by addressing the SSH issue and rebuild Guardian Agent.
Guardian Agent is a tool, uh,
that enables secure delegation for the SSH protocol.
Our tool consists of an authentication agent running on the user's,
uh, local machine on her laptop.
Um, it consists of a custom SSH client,
uh, that you can run on the- your- on your cloud machines,
or any other partially trusted machine on which you wanna run,
uh, operations using SSH but you don't want to put your key on.
And the nice thing is that our- our protocol and
our tools are backwards compa- compatible with existing SSH servers,
so you don't really need to modify the SSH server.
So, you don't really need to go and- and wait for GitHub to adopt our solution,
and you can get practical,
uh, security benefits today.
Uh, so let me tell you about how does Guardian Agent work.
Um, so in the setting we have
the local machine that keeps the private key and running our agent,
we have the delegate running the custom client,
and we have GitHub as the server.
So, er, the first thing- the fir- uh,
when the delegate wants to run the command,
uh, he's gonna- instead of running the command directly on the server,
he's gonna talk, uh,
to the local machine through- through
the Guardian Agent protocol and request the agent, uh,
to run the command, uh,
and specify which server,
uh, he wants to run the command on.
Then the agent can prompt the user and make sure that the user actually,
uh, that the user actually approves the operation.
And in this- in- in this way the, uh,
the Guardian Agent, uh,
local machine gets the- the command,
gets the identity of the server and can also identify,
um, ide- identify the delegate based on the incoming connection.
Then if the user approves the operation, uh,
the local machine starts a connection to the server,
authenticates using the private key, and issues the command.
So, uh, at least we can see that
the local machine has control over
the- over all- all the parameters that we want to control,
the identity of the server and the,
uh, and the command and so forth.
But this seems kind of,
um- kind of, uh,
naive in- in the sense that if we just do it
this way we're kind of losing all the benefits,
uh, for which we wanted to delegate in the first place.
So, we really want it to run the command on the delegate,
and we don't want to run on the local machine for whatever we wanted to do,
and even tunneling the entire connection
through the local machine isn't really practical,
because imagine you were just running on-
riding on a train and you have a ve- very bad connection,
you don't really want to tunnel
the entire Git repository you're cloning through your local connection,
you just want to get it from the server to the delegate.
So to do that- what,
uh- the final step of our protocol is basically handing off the SSH connection
from the local machine to the Git- to
the delegate in a way that it's transparent to the server.
This way only the first part of establishing the connection which is really, uh,
minimal in terms of the required bandwidth
happens between the local machine and the server,
and then the connection can be resumed directly between
the delegate and the SSH server so the entire contents of this,
let's say, Git- Git- repository, in this case,
will be transferred directly from the server to the delegate.
Um, so, uh, how do we do this,
uh- how do we do it- do it this SSH handoff?
And to kind of, um,
think of it abstractly what we really want to do is we want to
serialize the entire state of the SSH client,
send it to the delegate and then de-serialize and resume the connection.
But if we look at what does the SSH state consist of,
it contains a- a lot of messy details.
It contains, uh, of the session ID and
the sequence number and all the details of the, um,
uh, of- of what command I'm running and most annoyingly,
it has a lot of crypto details.
So, every time you establish an SSH connection you need to negotiate an algorithm for,
um- for key exchange,
and for MACing, for encryption,
and every- each such algorithm contains a lot of
state that evolves as the connection continues.
You, uh- you have IVs, you have counters,
and just serializing this in general would require either support from
each individual cipher or has to- have- or having to fix the cipher mode,
and we don't really want to do that.
So, to avoid doing this kind of messy serialization what we do is we use, um,
a feature already provided to us by the SSH protocol and
this is that we can we- we can run a key re-exchange on an existing connection.
And the nice thing about key re-exchange is
as you can see here is that all the crypto state is
actually refreshed when you'd- when you- when- when
you do the key re-exchange which is sort of what we need.
Um, so how do we do- how we- do we use this, uh, key re-exchange?
So, we start by having two separate SSH connections,
one between the delegate and the local machine,
and the second one between the local machine and the server.
And initially, those two connections are independent.
Then, uh, after the local machine has sent the command, uh,
o- on its connection with the server, uh,
and a key re-exchange is triggered on both connection.
But this time, the key- the parties in
the key re-exchange are the delegate and the server,
and the local machine only acts as a relay that passes around,
uh, uh, the key exchange messages.
And kind of as a nice,
a- a- as a basic property of key re-exchange,
what you end up having is you end up having a shared,
um- a shared key between the two endpoints namely,
the delegate and the server.
So, once we're done, uh, once we're done with the key re-exchange,
we essentially have, uh,
an SSH connection now between the delegate and the server.
And there are a couple of mo- a couple of-
the messy details that you need s- still need to take care of,
uh, but they are very minimal and don't depend,
for example, on the crypto being used.
And one last thing that needs to be taken care of is that we want to avoid the delegate,
uh, being able to issue additional commands after the handoff.
So, to do that, before we initiate the handoff we use, um,
an already existing, uh,
extension to the SSH protocol,
uh, available for, uh,
in OpenSSH called no more sessions which allows the local machine to, uh,
um, to request from the server not
to honor any additional commands that's gonna be, uh, issued after that.
This essentially locks down the session to the particular command.
And, uh, maybe- maybe something that, uh,
jumped to your mind when- while I was describing this,
where we- we also have a couple of constraints on
the transport layer that we need to take care of.
For example, the agent might not even have direct connectivity with the server,
because maybe you're connecting to the delegate and it needs to connect to some,
uh, server which is not accessible from your local machine.
And second, as I've told you we want this to
become fully compatible with existing servers,
um, uh, so the entire connection- thi-
this entire handoff needs to be transparent from the server's point of view.
So, to address both of these concerns,
what we do is that we- the delegate acts as
a relay on the transport layer between the local machine and the server,
and then after the handoff he can reuse
the same TCP connection to talk to the server directly.
So, jis- this achieves both benefits.
So, this really allows the local machine to have connectivity with the server,
and also from the server's point of view, uh,
he- throughout the entire connection,
he talks over the same connection and it looks transparent.
Um, so Guardian Agent, uh,
uh- we implemented Guardian Agent,
it is available and already used,
um, by people online.
So, you can- I- I invite you to go on GitHub and use it.
[NOISE]
Um, and kind of the- the main part of the talk I want
to kind of discuss about how Guardian Agent both as a tool and those fine-grained,
uh, fine-grained delegation principles can actually be extended to additional settings.
And specifically, I'm gonna talk about, uh,
pri- uh, I'm going to talk about talking pri- privilege elevation.
So what's privilege elevation?
So I think most of you are again familiar with the need to
run the sudo command for example to install some program.
And the reason that you need to do it is,
well, you usually run, uh,
using some un- un- unprivileged account and you have some operation that you
want to do which requires more privileges.
And so again sudo is kind of ubiquitous.
You run it and then it asks you for your password and once you confirm your password,
uh, the entire process runs as root.
So what's the ki- what's the problem with this?
So there are kind of two issues with it.
The first issue is that, uh,
if- if you- if you hope that sudo would allow you to have
some security separation between your unprivileged account and your privileged account,
then it doesn't really, uh, it doesn't really do that.
And specifically, it doesn't really withstand an atta- an attacker
that manages to compromise the unpriv- the unprivileged account.
Such an attacker can, for example,
wait for you to run sudo for- for
some legitimate cause and then try and phish your password,
modify the command and this can be done using like
very basic modifications even to your shell script.
Um, so sudo is still good for preventing yourself from making a mistake,
but it's not- I- I- I kind of claim that it's not really,
um, suitable to give this extra security,
uh, extra security guarantees between your unprivileged account and the root account.
And second, if you look at the way that this mechanism work,
it's that after you approve, uh,
after you approve the privilege elevation and even if ki- the program,
uh, to which you gave these elevated privileges is ah- a legitimate program,
it is in fact the one that you want to- the one that you want to run,
you still kind of give it a- you- you give it
full root privileges that are unrestricted in scope.
And so you're allowing it to do anything that root can do rather than the-
perhaps a single operation that you wanted to give it these extra pri- privileges for.
And this is dangerous mostly because programs can have, ah,
programs can be exploited either due to memory bugs or some logical security bugs,
and whenever this privilege- you basically increase your attack surface
because whenever this priv- whenever this privilege process gets compromised you lose f-,
uh, you lose full control of your machine.
So, um, our idea is kind of to
use the same principles behind Guardian Agent to solve this,
uh, to solve this problem or maybe not to solve,
but kind of to improve the state of the world,
uh, when it comes to privilege elevation.
Um, so how do- how- how are we solving this?
So, again consider the scenario where we have a local machine, and the one that, uh,
has your credentials, the one that you use locally,
and now consider a case when you want to run sudo on some remote machine.
And I- I wanna know that the same kind of principles can be applied
to running sudo even on your local machine but then you need to take care of, uh,
trusted path issues, uh,
such as you need still to- you still need to have somewhere where
you can enter your password or interact with the machine,
uh, in a secure way.
But for simpli- simplicity,
let's just look at the remote scenario.
So, uh, with our- with our solution,
instead of running the apt-get binary using sudo and elevating the entire process,
the process is going to run, uh,
using the normal user privileges.
So this obviously won't work.
So what do we do, um,
so what we do is that we run a separate privileged daemon that
will take care of elevating privileges in a mine- much more fine-grained way.
And we also have a small library running within,
uh, the unprivileged- unprivileged process.
So everything on the left here, uh,
the apt-get process and the library is unprivileged and we have one privileged daemon.
So when the apt-get process is going to, uh,
do some operation which requires those extra privileges, the one,
uh, that we actually originally needed sudo for,
then obviously this operation is going to fail.
So, for example, uh, in this case,
it's going to try and open some fi- protected file which you cannot write as
an unprivileged user and operating system were
gonna tell- is going to tell the process, well, you can't do that.
Access is denied. Uh, in this point,
our library is going to intercept that system call just before it returns to- to
the program and request
the authentication agent running on your machine
to approve this operation which was originally denied.
Uh, again, same as before now the user can be prompted.
He can make sure that he's approving whatever he, uh,
whatever he wants, uh, to be performed on that remote machine.
And once the operation is approved,
a signed approval using the user's private key is sent,
uh, from the local machine, er,
to this library running in the unprivileged process.
Now, this unprivileged process can present the signed approval to
the privileged daemon and request for this operation to be performed on its behalf.
The privilege daemon verifies the- verifies the signature,
verifies the parameters of the operation,
and then goes- goes ahead and performs this operation from the privileged context.
Er, in this case, for example,
it opens the file,
gets the file descriptor and passes the file descriptor back to the unprivileged daemon.
So as you can see here, uh, as a result,
we've managed to perform a privileged operation from an unprivileged process without, uh,
first of all, by allowing the user to control this specific operation and
without increasing the attack surface and running the entire process as root.
Um, so this is kind of what we're working on now.
And it turns out that kind of
this personal auth- authentication agent that we're building opens also,
uh, new opportunities for other things to be done.
So once we have this one focal point for all authorization decisions,
uh, for the user,
this allows us to, uh,
look for other new, uh,
possibilities for example, uh,
running a personal authorization log that will have, um,
that will have a log of all operations that- that were
performed users- using the user's identity and allow,
uh, allow the user to ask questions such as,
how was my identity used?
What privilege operations did I approve?
And make sure that his identity wasn't misused.
And second, once all, uh,
once all operations on behalf of the user kind of are
strongly tied to the user's cryptographic identity,
to his private keys located in one place,
we can then go and, uh,
maybe thi- think about other scenarios such as splitting the key between the user's, uh,
hardware token and some trusted server, uh,
in a way- in a way to enable, uh,
things like- such as two factor authorization and so on.
So, kind of to conclude, uh,
I thi- I think that the main point, um,
that you should take away from this talk is that, um,
we want to give user the power to really control the way that their identity is used.
Uh, not only- like to control every oper-
every operation individually with a much finer scope.
And Guardian Agent is a step towards this.
We provide secure, uh,
delegation for SSH and also secure privilege elevation.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
OAuth 2 is becoming quite popular and it's
an authorization framework rather than an authentication one.
Um, how would that affect the- the kind of thing you're doing?
Um, so I think for OAuth 2 it doesn't really use,
um, it doesn't really use cryptography to assert every,
er, every authori- every authorization operation that you do.
So you kind of need to, uh,
again trust some- some third party to- to store your, uh,
store your tokens and- and so on.
Okay.
Any other questions?
How do you handle for- for privilege escalation?
You have to deal with states on the server.
So, for example, if you have- if you have a symbolic link
and the user approves access to a symbolic link,
but then the link changes,
how do you- how do you- how do you handle things like that?
So, actually, symbolic link is- is really a source of,
uh, kind of trouble, but, uh,
what we do is we try to dereference
all- as much of the state as possible from the unprivileged context.
Uh, so for example, all symbolic links or relative parser
are evaluated in unprivileged process, and then,
uh, when the user approves this- approves the path he
can get- he gets an absolute path that he can assign some trust to.
Cool, yeah.
Any more questions?
Isn't there a kind of inherently, uh,
time to check time to use problem there even with dereferencing all these symbolic links?
Um, yes.
I think one idea that we have to address,
this kind of issues is for example, uh,
maybe not blocking, but alerting the user if any component
of the path let's say for file operation is writable by the unprivileged account.
Uh, and you can kind of think of an environment if all the components of
the path are not writable by the user, uh,
then it's not to- it shouldn't be susceptible to this kind of attack at least
from- There's- there's still
global state whenever- whenever you do which can be modified,
uh, concurrently, um, but I think it can minimize the risk of that.
How about situation how user is
allowed to perform actions on Machine A and not on Machine B.
So, if- if- if user is allowed to say run apt-get on Machine 1 whereas she's,
uh, I mean she's but then
she's not allowed to run on Machine B because it's only command?
Um, so from each machine keeps, um,
keeps a set of public keys of- that
corresponds to the users that are allowed to do this operation.
This is from the server's point of view and
from the agent's point of view when the user authorizes something,
it's actually presented also with identity of the s-.
So in the example that I gave you,
you will not only see that you are approving
apt-get but you also see the identity of the machine.
And this identity is going to be- to be inside
that- that blob of data that you are going to sign.
And then each machine can verify that its own identity was signed by the user.
How does the- the mechanism seems a lot like what Windows does.
Um, how does the user actually
know the answer to the question that the user is being asked?
Um, so- so I think there's like- you're bringing up two- two important issue.
First of all, I think that if you compare it to let's say the UAC mechanism in Windows,
so it- it- it- although you are given some prompt,
it still suffers from the problem that
the entire process gets elevated after you approve these things.
So you don't if- you still suffer from increasing the attack surface.
About the point that the user needs to make a decision, uh,
then kind of our hope is that on the agent side using the policy we can- we can kind of,
um, uh, present the question in a meaningful way.
For example, uh, not only show the full path,
but give some meta information about it.
I guess the answer
that I sort of sourced to my question was actually the authorization log.
That you could at least forensically go back and
say although you didn't understand that you were authorizing this,
you did actually authorize this and this was
the thing that caused you to be broken later, would be improved.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Great. Thanks Dima. [APPLAUSE]